en este campamento de refugiados
internos en el noreste de afganistán el
número de niñas que fueron obligadas a
casarse aumentó durante la hambruna de
2018 y se disparó este año con la sequía
los padres de esta niña dicen que han
sido llevados al límite han optado por
venderla en matrimonio para poder llegar
a fin de mes esta es mi hija de 8 años
la vendí por 2500 euros a causa del
hambre y de las deudas en los próximos
días vendrá el hombre que la compro y si
la llevara a su casa no tengo otra
opción esto no es algo bueno dios y su
mensajero nunca nos dijeron que
hiciéramos esto para otro padre que
vendió a sus dos hijas de nueve y seis
años el dinero se lo gastó en alimentar
a sus otros hijos y en pagar las
facturas médicas de su mujer sigue
endeudado y no ha visto a sus hijas
hace un año que no las veo no he visto a
las niñas se las llevaron no podemos
pagar el transporte para ir a verlas y
luego volver
estamos atrapados no podemos ir y volver
así que no hemos visto a los niños
su madre es un manojo de nervios por sus
hijos por toda la miseria
el gobernador de la provincia dice que
los matrimonios infantiles se deben a la
pobreza y no algo impuesto por los
talibanes que ahora gobiernan el país
desde su toma del poder se ha agravado
la crisis económica gran parte de la
ayuda internacional ha sido suspendida
el programa mundial de alimentos
advierte que más de la mitad de la
población casi 23 millones de personas
se enfrentarán a una grave inseguridad
alimentaria en este invierno